mind your decisions i'm presh tal walker
suppose ax plus b y is equal to five ax
squared plus b y squared is equal to 10x
cubed plus b y cubed is equal to 50 + 8
X to the power 4 plus B y to the power 4
is equal to 130 what is the value of 13
multiplied by X plus y minus XY minus
120 multiplied by a plus B this problem
is adapted from a mathematics Olympiad
of Nepal pause if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
now rather than individually solving for
x y a and B will solve for the quantity
X plus y the quantity X Y and the
quantity a plus B these will be easier
to solve for and we'll still have the
required information to evaluate the
original problem seeing this kind of
trick only comes from practice and from
solving many math videos per month so
let's get started we'll start with the
second degree equation we'll multiply
both sides by the quantity X plus y
well then distribute the left hand side
we're going to get another equation we
can now simplify this equation notice we
have a X cubed plus B Y cubed and that's
equal to 50 we substitute that for the
remaining two terms we factor out X Y
and we're left with a factor of ax + B Y
but this is interesting because we know
that's equal to 5 so we'll substitute
that in we'll now take this entire
equation and put it to the side we'll do
the same sort of process on the cubic
equation well multiply both sides by the
quantity x + y and then we'll distribute
the left hand side we're going to get
another equation which will have many
simplifications here a X to the power 4
plus B y to the power 4 is equal to 1/30
then we factor out X Y and we're left
with a factor x squared plus B y squared
this is equal to 10 which will
substitute we now consider these two
equations well multiply this second
equation by 2 so that the factor on XY
is equal to 10 we now subtract the
second equation and we'll eliminate the
entire XY factor from both equations we
get 30 is equal to 30 multiplied by the
quantity x + y we can then solve that x
+ y is equal to 1 we substitute that
back into the first equation and we can
solve that XY
is equal to negative eight we're making
good progress and now we'll consider the
linear equation we'll multiply both
sides by the quantity X plus y will then
distribute on the left hand side and
we're going to end up with an equation
which will simplify here ax squared plus
B y squared is equal to 10 then we
factor an X Y and we're left with a
factor of a plus B this equation we can
use the information we've already
derived here XY is equal to negative 8
and X plus y is equal to 1 we substitute
those in and that'll allow us to solve
for a plus B and we'll get a plus B is
equal to 5 over 8 from these three
pieces of information we can evaluate
our original problem we substitute in
and then we simplify and we get the
result of 42 it's amazing how often 42
is the answer to many things in life and
in the universe thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube as always thanks for watching
thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]